y'all want to eat fresh or make sure
y'all fresh and healthy put a whole
bunch of Bologna orangutan not a ring it
city what is the car oregano oregano hi
my name is Jonathan D Manor and I worked
at Subway for a total of six months and
my name is Mason and I worked at Subway
for two months my name is Teresa aka
freedom and I worked that subway for
about a year my name is Nick thir and I
worked at Subway for one week and today
we are answering your questions about
Subway all right here's our first
question
what is the grossest or weirdest
sandwich you have ever made I must say I
had a customer that I mean she was
pregnant which makes perfect sense I
mean I should've just asked for
everything that we had everything
everything everything everything every
sauce buffalo sauce sweet onion mustard
honey mustard like just you name it I
mean went on a sandwich I do remember
somebody ordered tuna mayonnaise buffalo
sauce pickles there's most of the
pickles in the tuna it just doesn't make
sense to me the tuna I hate the tool not
only does it come in a bag but like you
know after you take the bag off and you
just you put it inside the bowl and you
have to use like I think like six
gallons no I'm joking like I'm like a
lot a sandwich sandwich is there a
secret menu there's no secret maximize
there is no secret menu item folks I
mean if you want to pretty much make
your own sandwich into a secret meeting
menu item you can do that I mean but
other than that there's there's no
secrets everything that's out there is
that much I mean yes the only thing I
heard in the back was they would people
would buy chips and have you put them on
the sandwich for you the rumor to giving
customers of cookie dough is false
you cannot give customers cookie dough
unless you want to get fired I mean you
can I mean nobody's telling me
somebody's telling you that you can't
but I mean
Anette you're not supposed to give
customs go even thinks of stuff like
that what is the biggest thing customers
complain about the biggest thing for me
to customers complain about is the same
thing that how it went clean about I'm a
big man I need a big sandwich they
complain about Portia
why shouldn't you get as much chicken as
you go why shouldn't you get as much you
know of anything only thing you're
allowed to get unlimited is vegetables I
did double me for everybody salad you
did double me for everybody I hope they
don't come with double meat on people's
sandwiches I used to put a whole bunch
of vegetables like yeah y'all want to
eat fresh on make sure y'all fresh and
healthy a whole bunch of orangutan not a
bring it to you what is the car oregano
oregano pepper
olives whatever you want I didn't you
stop Pilate on there what is the worst
thing to make I'll probably say meatball
sandwich that is so sloppy you like the
bread is all soggy do you try to cut it
and then the meats just falling out sure
man you trying to enter aren't and the
meatballs is falling out and just people
who order like a lot on their sandwiches
like the more you put on your sandwich
the harder it is to close it and the
more aggravated I am cuz now like you
see the customer like looking like from
the glass and they're like making sure
that you close it properly and I'm like
dude everything's coming up why can you
only put six olives on a sandwich I just
threw them on that in a simple answer
portion control people what's wrong
we're not trying to give away to
restaurant we're not I'm not sure wish
why is the position called a sandwich
artist cuz it's an art it's not easy
making sandwiches god I don't know the
reason why the position is called a
sandwich artist is because you get a
footlong then we take that footlong key
take a knife and you get that knife you
can get it at a 45-degree angle and you
cut the bread a certain way and then you
open up that bread you show it's the
customer you tell them what kind of
vegetables would you like on your
sandwich today and that is why we are
called Subway sandwich artists
[Music]